foreign
[Music]
was sure that he knew my fiance from
somewhere Shady
I did a pin my search I'm assuming's
like I don't know what Pim eyes is but
I'm assuming it's like a you type
someone's name and you can find out
stuff about them I did a pimp ice search
and found her nasty from way back when
oh two huge problems oh okay one she hit
her pass from me
two she doesn't do the things that she
did online
that is a huge problem how do I confront
her
that's crazy to me that she does online
how do I confront her with this because
she doesn't know why no and why don't
you want to do that stuff to me you do
it to a stranger give it to a stranger
and get that [__] promoted for money
yeah yeah you won't do that to the love
of your life yeah yeah why yeah I want a
freak and you clearly you have the
capability yeah you have that in you
yeah but you just need that for me yeah
how much money to make you do it pay you
you're my wife yeah how much did they
pay you yeah fam
her nasty videos nasty and she told you
nothing about this
understandably yeah understandably yeah
because she wouldn't be sat there with a
ring on her finger
we all know that's true
she wouldn't be sat there with a ring on
the finger so I see where she lied I
would lie too yeah right in terms of
like why aren't you this nasty yeah yeah
why are you nasty with strangers you're
not nasty with me because what what do
you want from that because you're gonna
say
you ate is us from the back
I ain't never seen you do that to me so
what now you're gonna tell me to bend
over obviously not bearing in mind I
don't want that yeah yeah yeah I need to
know the levels you're capable of
reaching yeah but also like I also don't
want you doing it because I brought it
up
the whole Dynamics changed yeah yeah and
everyone wants sex anyway yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah I like I don't want
you now putting on that extra mile
because you because I confronted you
about it guilt guilt says because if you
wanted it you would do it we're engaged
bro I would just say babe random
hypothetical hypothetical
when you look at me
when you look at me yeah do you think
I would
do
anything to that man or do you think I
just love him and we have intercourse
do you think that like I want to drown
in his nut or do you think like that's
hubby do you think it's me as a cuddy
little teddy bear or do you think like
that's Jason Momo and I want him to
throw my head through the floorboards
like how do you see man yes yeah I can't
even ask you I don't really know I don't
want to know the answer I also don't
want to know the answer
but from the way you're moving
you're moving like I'm a little teddy
bear telling already yeah yeah your ass
is telling because I look at you and I
literally want to suffocate in between
your legs facts asphyxiate me right now
I would that's all I yeah I want you to
set my face until I die that's all I
think about that's what I want I want to
devour you it's all like that's what I'm
on that's the stuff I'm about that's
what I'm on
so how do you feel you know that you've
been sitting on my face yeah I've been
doing yes suffocating yeah
I'm trying to twist that nipple off
why are you on
and you see her give the madness up the
madness yeah so I know she has it in us
so then her response to what needs to be
like oh I need her to be like swear is
that what you're on Daddy is that what
you're on say like you're gonna ask me
twice I've been waiting for this day but
if that's not her answer I promise I'll
slide that ring straight off my finger
because if she because she can't tell me
yeah to be honest babe I'm just not that
I'm not I'm not sexual like that
that I can't hear that's a lie yeah
because yeah you're actively alive
that's a lie the worst part of it is is
that I'm I could go in there and be like
this is what I'm on what are you on and
she says say swear and then it turns out
I'm not on it do you know what I mean
yeah it turns out I'm like
a couple steps back yeah flips you away
she flips you open and I couldn't I
couldn't but now I've spoken up yeah
yeah so now I have to firm it
your cheeks have never clenched so quick
and she pries them open
spits and says are you really on it
Daddy I've been waiting for this
this
I will scream
James I would scream she said that's
what you said you were on
but Yuma will never hear it
but now that's just day one oh my God
I'm petrified now I'm petrified in my
own yard because when it comes to sexy
time I've got anxiety I've got fear yeah
and I don't want the sun to set yeah
that's why she's active I don't want the
sun to set
[Music]
yo
the sun to set Prada
it's dangerous when it's dark
it's dangerous when it's dark and I'm
not on it
I'm just not on it babes
don't scare me oh scare me bro that took
my legs from me oh that was funny I
don't want the sun to set I hear you on
that bro this is the rest of our lives
now because I got in my area yeah yeah
now we have to run it back and I have to
say this is what really happened I found
your sexy time vids and I got in my
feelings yeah I was I was hurting and
hating yeah I was hating I was hurting I
was thinking I'm a man yeah I want that
turns out I'm not a man and I don't fat
do you still love me
[Music]